what essentially is being done when you  fake a cdc vaccination record  is  you were using an official government  agency's seal  um  without authorization and that's a crime  okay so when people do that there may be  law written  to specifically go for faking  vaccination  but faking a cdc certificate is a crime  it can be punishable under title 18 us  code section 1017 and other laws so it  is a crime so you should report it if  you know of people that are doing this  this is really it's an attack on  humanity really because what you're  doing is you're endangering people  and the recommendation is you call 1-800  hhs tips  or  you can go to ic3.gov that's for  internet crime i don't know if it's  exactly an internet crime but that's  another recommendation so 1-800 hhs tips  or ic3.gov